So now let's try to apply the idea of pipelining
to a processor. In a traditional processor, that is, nowaday
is too simple so we only use it to teach
students, but it still shows how things work. We have
a program counter, we use the program counter, to act
as the instruction memory. We get the instruction from there.
We look at the instruction to decode it, to figure
out which type of instruction it is. Meanwhile we could be
reading our registers. Once we have read our registers, we can
feed them to the ALU, where we are going to do the
add or subtract or an XO or whatever the instruction wants
us to do. The decoding logic is going to tell the ALU
what to do. Once we get the result of the ALU,
we could be done and just write the result to the
register, or we could have a load or a store instruction.
In which case, what the ALU computed is really the address
that we use to access our data memory, and what
comes out of data memory is what we end up
writing to our registers. And then of course there is
stuff to do with branches and so on, but basically
we can do one instruction per cycle by starting at
the BC, fetching the instruction, accessing the registers, doing the
operation, accessing the data memory and then writing the result
back to registers. So you can see that the instruction
kind of goes through these five phases. We fetch
the instruction, we read registers and decode, we
use the ALU, we access the memory and
finally, we write the register. The time to
do this might be something like 20 nanoseconds.
So now we can do one instruction every
20 nanoseconds. So how do we apply pipelining
to this? Well, the idea is that if here
we have our fetch, the code, ALU memory and width part
of this processor. And here we show what happens in cycle one.
We will fetch some instruction I1. In cycle two instruction
I1 moves to decode. In cycle C3 instruction I1
will be doing the aerial operation. In cycle C4 I1 will
move to do memory, and then in cycle C5 I1 will write the result. And the next
cycle we can begin the instruction two. If
we do that, then we really will finish one
instruction every 20 nanoseconds. If we apply the
idea of pipelining here, in cycle one, we are
still fetching instruction I1. In cycle two, we will
be decoding instruction I1, but we can begin fetching
the instruction I2. When instruction I1 move to do the ALU operation, I2 can
move to be decoded and I3 can be fetched. In the fourth cycle, I1 is the memory
stage, I2 will be doing the ALU operation, I3 will be here being decoded and I4
will be fetched. And then when I1 is in the last part of the pipeline,
I2 will be right after it in the
memory state. I3 will be doing the ALU operation.
I4 will be decoded, and we will be
fetching an instruction I5. So now the idea is
that once the I1 leaves the pipeline, very
soon after that I2 will leave the pipeline. If
we divide this 20 nanosecond into five equal pieces
for these stages, each stage will be four nanoseconds.
And now, the latency to do I1 is till
20 nanoseconds. So it takes 20 nanoseconds to do
an instruction. But the throughput will be one instruction,
will finish every four nanoseconds because once I1 leaves,
that's how long it takes for I2 to leave,
and then we just keep pouring instructions out. So,
it's similar to the oil pipeline. It takes a
while to fill the pipeline, but once we do,
instructions keep pouring out at a very high rate.